Tyrese halberton first triple double of
his career first of many 26 points 13
dimes and 10
rebounds just another night at the
office as he stands by with Stephanie
very well said sparo uh congratulations
Tyrese your first career triple double
you told me before the game that this
was probably the most important game of
your career did it live up to the hype
for sure for sure uh the atmosphere was
crazy our fans were amazing um it was a
lot of fun I love this we also talked
about defense it's been something that
you all have known you've had to work
with we saw in the third quarter the
defense turned this game around can you
all sustain that moving forward yeah for
sure for sure I was doing an awful job
in the first half I was getting attacked
couldn't breathe had to hit inhaler at
halftime but uh you know I figured it
out team figured out I had a lot of
support behind me and the coach staff
did a great job drawing some some
different things up to give them
different looks and we were able to get
the win tonight okay so now you you are
the first team to advance to the first
ever in season tournament semi-final in
Las Vegas your expectations and what
that means to this team and this city
expectation is to win um we're coming
out here we're a young hungry group and
we want to win every night so uh we're
excited to be there but we're not just
complacent being there we want to win so
we'll uh celebrate this one tonight pack
we got to leave tomorrow and uh get
ready to play the New York Milwaukee
thanks for stopping nice job thank you
appreciate it guys all right Stephanie
great stuff as the ascend
star gets his postgame water bath and
he's going to lead his Pacers to Las
Vegas in the
semis of the NBA in season tournament
what a
performance